okay this one is this one looks pretty
Larry's life
Larry's law all right it's ten rights
will be Larry
let's do Larry's life Larry's life part
one okay
don't wonder what his life is like how
do I it's probably amazing we're all
we're gonna find out that's the point
right
it's true I don't even know if I
remember how to download I mean do these
installers il come to me as soon as I
hit download I'm sure we just resend a
snapchat snap you snap [ __ ] didn't flare
just snapped child my girlfriend oh well
that's because she's in college right
now so she's just like UGA's and he
snapped chance like alright well what is
the new snapchat of the Skype call I'm
in right now so you know I'm doing so
you know she's you're not cheating on
her but I mean technically it it make it
oh dude she's gotten so much flak
because she's like she thinks the whole
Peter I think is like stupid like where
people draw us [ __ ] in [ __ ] anyhow
we're like we don't give a [ __ ] yeah
but the fans who just like well March is
cooled it so you have to be too and now
she's just like a so pissed I was like
she's she feels like she's not allowed
to have her own if anyone thinks oh
you're not allowed to have opinions on
the internet no it's so [ __ ] stupid
but honestly mindset isn't like it
either she seen thinks is weird like who
doesn't love it's weird dude I think
it's hot I mean it it's hot it's totally
works and are you recording this
I am boner day constant boner bro dude
alone Ernie everyday boner pie that's my
new favorite that's a good one okay I'm
in her game oh let's see it getting
install this gotta go to custom stories
no legit
ah then nostalgia lucious game up and
forever I uh I
kind of sad right now I am very sad
notice I'm playing the game I think I
lost my old files like my old custom
sorry I was making I thought I saved it
no it's not forever yeah oh man I'm sad
I would be sad so sad oh man there damn
it your likes if you're not nearly sad
as I know some people are gonna be for
watching this blackness oh yeah they're
gonna be there is no you they should be
happy that we're playing amnesia yeah
it's like this way you want right right
I got to turn off the lights otherwise
people are gonna complain oh yeah make
sure you get the atmosphere just proper
let's see just proper yep Oh see here
there we go in there off time crunch
game yeah I gotta make sure this is
gonna record properly I wanted to have
like the audio too low or too high or
something man you know what I mean
oh I hate mine ain't happens but it's
like our first video is in a nutshell
yeah I see yeah just talk a little bit I
guess hello how are you doing I'm
talking to myself
so cracking Jake its audio thank you
you're welcome
let's check that out
oh yeah I'm gonna have to up the
brightness remember the game gets wicked
dark oh yes playing all the time yeah I
can't see anything even though you can't
see anything I said like we can't see
anything either yeah every single time
god I need your [ __ ] playthroughs oh
the full fullness alley i came here when
i changed the gamma rah
alright oh man i'm looking at the title
screen so let me know when you're doing
that i think i got a lower the option or
the audio and the options Oh make sure
to disable hints uh I never ever done
that so I know I wanted to keep to my
roots alright alright what'swhat's your
gamma set to right now Oh every that
picky I I'm just curious one point seven
one point seven mm-hmm that about you
that's
1.7 is really high yeah that's that's
how I roll
really I'm all over that gamma that's
that's a lot of gamma you so judge me
all right
III don't see you bye bye mr. Nord 94 it
is by also you're in the title screen
now yeah okay I'll let you read their
first sentence we can take turns
I'll do how I used to do a long time ago
okay
I want to hear this I don't know hello
audience and welcome to Larry is
sentenced to death you did audience no
oh but I apparently used to pretend I
was Tobuscus back in the day you did
your tobe tribute yeah absolutely
he was got a gun I don't what you will
win the second okay Larry sentenced to
death very sinister death I'm crying
that is not what Ryan find out as you
reveal Larry's past I'm gonna start now
no we gotta do it simultaneously okay
all right three mmm - mm-hmm one drink
Lucknow dari I clicked okay
- good what if yours lose fast I wanna
have the voice acting he doesn't sound
39 no come on
I like how those arms are just hanging
out there that's why they are moving
they're really good at good at miming
those prisoners they're really good at
building up the life of Harry okay
ah did we actually get the player what
is this we gotta face it just that we
just gotta face it like face towards it
oh no why oh I can move
oh yeah oh my god oh my god we can't
move I can't move like my mouse know
anything
oh they want us to enter the Iron Maiden
all right you know we have this yeah we
have to sink it
all right I'm like right next to the
first lump of people Oh cam right in
front of it okay all right I
I'm so so annoyed this I'm so scared of
these spikes they gonna poke me Amy I'm
not gonna like it
are we gonna go in right now yes we're
going the wrong way we got to go inside
of it okay now I'm turned wait wait I'm
not in yet what I'm going in now I can't
oh no oh my god Wow mr. Noah 94 proudly
presents a Nordic production and we got
some drama up here this is dramas [ __ ]
this is amazing
Wow this is a new Michael Bay movie you
made the unforgiving game what there's
that oh I love that one that's my
favorite was the franchise oh we get to
enjoy part two I guess so I'm already
anticipating oh my god I love our
everything is there and everything do
you get that - I just get that that's a
lot of nor deny it is for everything by
Nord 94 mr. main I'm sorry oh [ __ ] I
step back oh he's got a web's website
gotta check that out yes I feel bad now
I'm being too mean to him we are here's
our eggs dude 94 I have a governing
plate I feel like I was a little head of
you yeah yeah you're a little bit ahead
of me okay every just a bit I'm almost
there I'm scared this this music still
okay musics done I'm in how does up
quick all right
12 years earlier yes so this is when he
or he was 90 39 then so this is where
he's 27
yeah all right good math good thank you
all right so I guess I'm just gonna
check these drawers then I predict it
may have a lot of pots in the closet I
don't know what's up shirts
I mean you needed him a lot of shirts if
you're Nord Oh make sure you get the
lantern on the desk oh I don't know if I
was allowed to click on stuff without
you
oh no no yeah
click on that stuff okay I didn't kill
them I see these pots you can't pick
them up though I feel like you're a
ghost in the room with me crying I would
pretty much are I'm not Aiden from
frickin beyond two souls sound my god
Aiden
oh hey I cry every time Aiden I'm gonna
go get you in trouble with your parents
then your dad's gonna be disowning you
and stuff how dare you Aiden
I know but only believe the scream yes
it's looking at a light now beyond 2
souls 2 is actually announced today
really well I don't know if it was an
Alex but it would like it's gonna well
there's a paper on here alright alright
you read it remember note 1 1 meet
Joseph and Katherine at the bank for the
robbed yeah read that again please
meet Joseph in captain for the
explicitly illegal thing that is very
bad because my mother didn't teach me to
be a good boy
so I better write it down in his note so
no one's I ever find out about it to
grab a crowbar from the study room from
now on there's no way back this is it
the moment of our lives there's no part
to and there's no part maybe we'll find
part 2 on part 2 because this is only
part 1
that's it that's it I enjoyed it I'm
going in I'm going in I mean the diner
okay I'm I'm in the Oh cry what are you
doing I don't know I'm just looking
around
this chair is oh I got a plate you got a
break a plate idler lead it'd it just
set it right that's been spooky [ __ ] man
oh there's a clipping texture alright
where every cousin sword needs one it's
right behind the like width of the room
there's one man statue yeah yeah that's
it it's inside it yeah beautiful I want
to break it I'm gonna go through the
door that's to the left okay let's go
that first you write aware of this book
right
I don't see any I don't neither what is
this son the crowbar in here alright I'm
a click the crowbar all right click they
know that I
okay all the know you get ass okay
remember no to a new crowbar with no
fingerprints on it just what I need from
today's action good thing you didn't
like write down what you were a serious
evidence if you care about glove for
Jesus did he even bit were they even
able to tell fingerprints back then or
whatever I think so I thought you were
okay I'm sorry then it's okay I
apologize yeah it's all right
please forget my action in life I know
I'm not perfect I'm no I'm not the
perfect man but this is my call this is
what we want this is for us all for now
for the future thank God I didn't have
to read more okay well what was that
about I don't know it's mysterious I
guess so oh there's a lot none ya wanna
know what it is that is av not been able
to save I - is blown right how many
years ago did you play this game how
many years
I don't laudanum oh my god London on the
left side there's a secret painting pull
it off this home oh oh oh another note
it's a bank security system no no man
cared okay
it's an aztlán I know I don't know where
that is Norway Oh it says all right I go
ahead I want to read it this is a modern
Bank in Oslo Norway today's action will
take the place here today's action oh
okay whatever the security is damn high
but only if you know how to bypass the
place is a lot of guards both outside
and inside I know the schedule for each
shift therefore we will begin when B
shift is over please do not be late we
need the time we have
Josef Frank Schleck it's Alisa I never
heard that name before
wow it sounds amazing shayana I'm taking
this giant painting with me it's gonna
be my Stefano [ __ ] how do you spot Oh
how are they are are yeah your whole
heart yeah you know all about rotating
no I
why would I know
it's ridiculous so do we need to use the
crowbar on the door I would ever know I
don't I don't know I just
are you came on I went by the door I'm
sorry you have to say Vitus gonna buy
buy paint fun oh I love this houses go
if you go out and look at the house
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I don't know it's
magic houses a clown bus it is it's like
the can I go back inside
oh my god text message holy [ __ ] walk Oh
Mike look towards the house okay look
like tor just walk towards it
walking to it whoa I can go up on the
roof I'm on the rope oh god oh
what happened you can go inside the roof
I don't want it forward I don't want to
go too far because I'm gonna fall out
thematic we probably will yeah okay I'm
on I'm on the roof this is cold hi dear
we're safe here
mates ow all right let's go back
negative
we got some great stuff so far I got a
text message so you have to read it cuz
I did you yeah if you keep walking out
oh okay uh I'm looking oh God text
message I tried to worry
you're late we had to start without you
meet us inside the bank use a broken
window more evidence good thing you've
thought about the fingerprints wait your
mother's right so this is during modern
day with text messages but we have a
lantern um don't question it crying God
all right you don't let how you don't
know safe Oh cry don't don't waste your
Lantern oh I'm sorry
I'm placing my lantern yeah how dare you
the modern day is are we time travelers
who went back in time and we're like
utilizing modern technology Thanks
yeah obviously how well using a crowbar
well is spooky things where I'm I took
the wrong turn I'm sorry wait wait
where did you go good yeah keep moving
forward and then oh my god good things
there's guards the guards are look at
their guards dude I don't even bother
him with this
yeah I'm like going insane by staring at
the guards I'm just gonna go to the left
okay
I'm going there too all right my buddies
think oh it says go to the left so
usually that means it works out there's
a lot of clipping bushes though oh Jesus
calm down bushes yeah there's a button
here behind this the signal there is you
want to click a laser system status
offline oh great I'm glad every bank
ever just puts a button like that
outside whatever the laser system is I
think it's great that they that they let
us do that let me just turn it off
Leonard yeah I'll fly okay shut up all
right all right the guards they're still
there though
yeah so let's keep going this other path
all right yeah so we'll go to the ripe
end
yep okay said here to the right there's
two trees inside each other
manhattan's don't don't say that that's
too scary for me that's that's not I'm
sorry this keep going and you'll find
the broken window all right what is this
this is not I'm never gonna drop windows
go okay I went inside did you go inside
though okay I'm now in the office area
of the bank better watch out for the
guards all right
better watch out all right Oh so they
use monsters as guards okay then yeah
this very well secured bank mm-hmm huh
it'll keep all of the 12 year olds out
all right so this an elevator anyway oh
yeah wait did I like that like we
couldn't progress without picking up the
crowbar so if we did we would
technically not be able to finish them
at probably you're right you are right I
hate when they do that okay so I can
only click the one going down I think we
might want to check the rooms first that
okay you're right well what there's a
phone if you keep going forward I
already got that wait how do you cry oh
god cried the gods the gods cry oh god
the gods but the gods the gods the guy
okay the god of Bank I'm gonna go right
all right let's lock door I'm gonna try
to open on the crowbar
yeah it works really yeah groovy nice
you're Jay and you crowbars exploded
because for some reason every crowbar
you ever bring on a bank heist breaks
with one use how unfortunate did those
two doors and you're left around are
both locked you're right there's one
slightly open that seems suspicious
yeah that one let's let's check it out
yeah now there's a bunch of buttons oh
that was that's scared I think was slow
that was easy warned you about that that
was a bank system that was their laser
system probably malfunctioning are only
one of these buttons of works it's the
top middle one so top Malik got it I
guess impressed I would turn the
elevator on yeah even though it was
broken
oh my god I'm gonna bring the chairs
chair Fano let's go hey it's mr. chair
how dare you I'm so sorry I don't know
all of your amnesia browse and he has
feelings all right Jesse really it's a
pretty piece of wood I mean I'm gonna go
where the go you know over the gods went
and the gods closed the door
oh the gods know yeah the god sorry yeah
oh no I wasted on my Latin oh you did
why do you even have your Lantern out
it's freakin brightest Helen hi I'm a
rookie at amnesia game it's all right
it's okay compass just just come to the
elevator I was and then you tell me to
get back got it okay all right are you a
little bit arena I have my chair with me
all right I did too
okay I suppose down down down we go
we're going down I wonder if the chair
will ah damn it mr. chair it's gone oh
you're welcome
I am welcomed okay let's go
Oh text message pay attention the code
to the ball is two four seven six don't
forget that okay here's I remember here
too for right I'll remember seven six uh
oh god I did it but I do the wrong one
or the right one I
Oh God Lois I told you the code was two
four seven five my bad [ __ ] you Joseph
Joseph you son of a [ __ ]
oh my god we're gonna get caught now it
was a trap my friends never we're never
there she
wait you what you told yourself or I
work you don't get sensitive maiden in
modern day life for robbing a bank
oh my god is not what happens
[ __ ] walk to the iron man I am
walking into it tell me when you're
there I'm almost there I'm there okay
just almost there almost almost there to
accept my fate as a bank robber all
right I posted for going going in now
I'm so immersed by walking into an
Ironman who is he gonna revenge himself
like oh this song that fits almost there
but what do we get Wow Brava 94 you're
my favorite you're my favorite you're
the bass is a made-up story and the vent
did never happen Oh what is Roberts
crime it shouldn't be attempted by
anyone
I really really hate your life if you
really hate your life guys you can
commit crimes if you want to oh my god
that took a weird turn
I don't know it I'm speechless I was
amazing [ __ ] dude and people wonder why
I don't play custom stores anymore
we don't know him anymore listen that
was a work of art okay we can't
criticize it monster guards in modern
day society with lanterns with lasers
and laser systems with a window that's
not a window I didn't see the window but
that's not a window I don't do you mean
the gate that they did the bridge yeah
where you entered the blue where you
enter the bank that giant barge oh that
was what that was
yeah yes well I was immersed tell him
well yeah that was 10 out of 10 for you
I mean no
probably to stand a half maybe four out
of ten four out of ten thank you very
much if you like this custom sorry
please go to the frictional games for
more the mod zv website until the
creator yourself yes through that is
that are you in them ads are we always
headed them yep okay yeah i'd to make
sure i get it through man now you got a
brofist so we'll be done here i have to
ask for like salsa Oh Mike I do like
this video
oh please [ __ ] sellout
it's not even selling out it's just
self-advertisement but it is a little
cheeky cheeky it's just it's what people
do something I mean I don't I don't do
it I just wear it it's against myself
even though you do do it
I mean can we just pretend that I don't
do it so we can push you want okay want
to still be friends bro day every day
Beauty crying hashtag uh let's go look
at pictures of us getting drawn [ __ ]
each other that's what we do many any
Dame that's what we're gonna do right
now send me the URL please you got it